welcome to the 38th season of Survivor  [Music]  here's a sobering thought in less than  72 hours the first person will be voted  out that's how fast this game moves and  every season it gets a little more  complicated a little more difficult to  win no matter how good you are you are  always hovering on the edge of being  voted out just think of the history of  great Survivor players who have yet to  win in fact let's just invite for them  to join you this season  but two favorite players are Kelly  Wentworth and my total survivor crushes  Joe and so we see the boat coming and  then you see the blonde now Mike that's  freakin Kelly Wentworth and then it gets  closer than like that Joe  [Applause]  [Music]